Jason wasn't afraid to put his other
on-screen rival to rock on blast what's
been embarrassing thing about Dwayne
that we may not know he's afraid of
heights he gets motion sickness the
reason he drives those big trucks is
because they're quite long so when he
was in the McLaren if you had to say to
Cutler motion sickness pills before it's
a true fact
Jason isn't the only one given up secret
Superman we found out the famous black
Superman line was actually changed the
title used to be black bond but interest
said it was too close to those rumors he
would be the next double-oh-seven the
sexiest man alive black Superman which
one do you like better uh sexiest man as
long as I'm alive I am the sexiest
that's what Dwayne told me to say
earlier oh really
Idris serves up some amazing stunts yeah
most of the action scenes are actually
him and he gave me a little personal
tour of the sweet rides used in the film
it's all car you want to get in like
that five six moves at once
punch kick head butt roll run come back
kick again and cut that's so cool by the
end of it I just want my bed
representing for the ladies is the crown
star of Vanessa Kirby you are a king
head-to-toe good monk oh and if action
and funny isn't enough there's yet
another reason to check out the film two
of the best cameos I've seen in movies
for a long long time with it you'd have
to be really miserable not to enjoy this
film the cameos are amazing they're
laugh-out-loud funny Hobbs a chart hits
theaters on Friday
[Applause]
[Music]